شَقْشَقَ الصُبحُ الجَمِيلْ  بَينَ زَقْزَقَةٍ وهَدِيلْ
اعْتَلىَ الدِّيِكُ يَصِيِحُ  سَطْحَ مَنْزِلِنَا يَقُولْ
مُوووو مُوووو
إنه صوت بقرة
أَيُّهَا الدِّيكُ الفَصِيحْ  صَاحِبُ الصَّوْتِ المَلِيِحْ
إِنَّهُ صَوْتٌ بَقَرةْ  مَا َكَذَا الدِّيَكَةُ تَصِيحْ
دِيكُنَا مَا عَادَ يَذْكُرْ كَيْفَ صَوْتُ الدِّيكِ فَكَّرْ
شَقْشَقَ الصُّبْحُ فَقَامْ  صَاحَ فَوْقَ البَيْتِ بَكَّرْ
مَاااء مَاااء
إنه صوت شاة
أَيُّهَا الدِّيِكُ الفَصِيحْ  صَاحِب الصَوتِ المَلِيحْ
إَنْهُ صَوْتٌ َشَاةٍ  مَا كَذَا الدِّيَكَةْ تَصَيَحْ
شَقْشَقَ الصُّبْحُ الْلَّطِيفْ  هَزَّ أَوْرَاقَ الخَرِيفْ
أَيْقَظَ الدِّيكَ لِيَصْحُوْ  صَائِحًا فَرَحاً يُضِيفْ
مِيَااااو مِيَااااو
إنه صوت قطة
أَيُّهَا الدِّيكُ الفَصِيحْ صَاحِب الصَّوْتِ المَلِيحْ
إِنَّهُ صَوْت ِقطَّةْ مَا كَذَا الدِّيَكَةْ تَصِيحْ
مَا أَرَقَّ الصُّبْحَ غَنَّى فَبَدَا الحَقْلُ كَجَنَّةْ
دِيكُنَا وَالفَجْرُ أَقْبَلْ صَاحَ وَالصَّوْتَ سَمِعْنَا
بقباااااق بقباااااق
إنه صوت بطة
أَيُّها الدِّيِكُ الفَصَيحْ  صَاحَب الصَّوْتِ المَلِيحْ
إَنَّهُ صَوْتٌ بَطَّة مَا كَذَا الدَّيَكَةْ تصيح
كَالصَّبَاحَاتِ النَّدِيَّةْ  دِيكُنَا حَسَنُ الطَّوِيَّةْ
قَامَ نَعْسَاناً يُؤَذِّنْ  عَلَّهَا تَصْحُو البَرِيَّةْ
هَااو هَاااو   هَااو هَاااو
إنه صوت كلب
أَيُّها الدِّيِكُ الفَصَيحْ صَاحَب الصَّوْتِ المَلِيحْ
إِنَهُ صَوْتُ كَلْب ما كَذَا الدِّيَكَةْ تصيحْ
فَكَّرَ الدِّيكُ وَفَكَّرْ  فِي صَبَاحٍ قَامَ أَبْكَرْ
اسْتَعَدَّ وَشَدَّ عُرْفَهْ  وَاسْتَطَالَ يَصَيحُ أَكْثَرْ
كُوووكُوووكُوووو
إنه صوت الديك
أَيُّها الدِّيِكُ الفَصَيحْ صَاحَب الصَّوْتِ المَلِيحْ
هكذا الديك يُؤَذِّنْ أَنْتَ أَهْلٌ لِلمَدِيِحْ
كُوووكُوووكُوووو